à mi chemin entre la cx et la gs la bx
est une voiture de la classe moyenne
supérieure
le modèle de base la bx 14 et une six
chevaux l'abbé x16 le modèle présenté
sur ces images une sept chevaux pour
produire cette voiture la firme du quai
de javel a investi 1 milliard 400
millions de francs
un investissement pourtant limité grâce
à l'utilisation d'études techniques
conçues pour l'ensemble du groupe
peugeot ainsi rien que pour concevoir et
construire le moteur sans l'aide du
groupe citroën aurait dû dépenser deux
milliards de francs
pourtant si la bx utilise bon nombre de
sous-ensembles peut jouer ça elle reste
une citroën fidèle à la tradition
suspension hydropneumatique confort
aérodynamisme selon ses constructeurs ce
nouveau modèle devrait à la fois
contenté les citroënistes convaincu mais
aussi touché le clientèle nouvelle
c'est une voiture qui a été résolument
pensée pour le marché européen
elle sera plus compétitif parce qu'elle
est plus moderne elle apporte des
éléments nouveaux
c'est une voiture qui est par exemple
très économique à toutes les vitesses
c'est une nouveauté je crois absolue
jusqu'à présent faisait des voitures
économiques à condition que le
conducteur s'en occupe et conduisent à
l'économie là c'est une voiture qui est
très économique
même lorsqu'on l'a conduit dans ses
performances
et elle a des performances qui sont tout
à fait intéressante cela parce que non
seulement elle a un très bon coefficient
aérodynamique mais aussi parce que nous
avons fait un effort considérable sur
l'allègement des poids de la voiture
notamment par l'utilisation de métaux
nouveau et de matériaux de composites
nouveau la bx ce sera livré avec deux
types de moteurs 13 160 et 15 180
centimètres cubes ainsi que trois
niveaux de finitions différentes pour
s'installer au volant il en coûtera de
48000 à 59 1800 francs enfin détail qui
a son importance la production de la bx
va créer 500 emplois
citroën de rennes
[Musique]